all right bradley yes bradley where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally uh bakersfield california i
spent most of my life out there so
i mean
other than that i moved around a lot um
i want to say big bear
victorville all that all that good stuff
tell me about your family my family my
family uh there
i lived with my uh my sister my mom and
my stepdad you know we were we were kind
of poor you know we had a but we we got
through with it you know we we made it
through with what we had to do you know
so uh
other than that i mean
i had a pretty good childhood you know
how far during school i want to say 11th
grade 11th grade i dropped out you know
so uh i got into like the music and the
and the the
the partying and girls and all that so i
i kind of i kind of messed that one up
but uh yeah i had a my i just met my
brother too in high school um
from another
same dad different mother but uh
he kind of influenced me to uh
get into traveling and whatnot
traveling in in what way uh we we we
were
he taught me how to hop hop freight
trains you know so we had like a little
a little crew we got together and uh
got into the community like like uh they
call us dirty kids at the time you know
so
it's still it's still a big movement um
i want to say san francisco they they
they a lot of the time they gather there
on on hate street if you've heard of it
like
like grateful dead kind of movement kind
of thing is still going you know so
there's a lot of a lot of train hopping
communities still and a lot of people
don't even know
that drugs are a part of that scene uh
somewhat somewhat not as much as anymore
mostly just like drinkers and stuff but
drugs would make it really hard to
travel you know because
if you have if you become dependent on
something like that you would have to
make the effort to look for it you know
so it's hard to do in a new place
so and drugs are a part of your life or
i was an alcoholic yeah i was an
alcoholic
i struggled with drugs a little bit i
want to say heroin for for a little
while i got i ended up getting clean
uh i got motivated to get clean get a
job and uh
you know start my life up
but other than that yeah yeah right now
i'm i'm i'm clean you know so i drink
here and there but that's it
where do you stay
uh currently i'm actually homeless
so i was recently evicted i i got my
section eight and uh
i yeah that whole thing got all messed
up
it's just some [ __ ] you know so
i'm just out here on the streets
trying to figure out a way to get get my
housing back
you know get back on track you prefer to
be
housed and stable than train hopping
um honestly
if if
if i could go back and do it again i
probably would yeah
but um
other than that i'd rather i'd rather
settle down you know because
in the end uh
we all got to at some point
you know and it's going to take its toll
on me you know i mean if i if i want to
keep living that life it's going to take
a toll because it does it takes a toll
on people tell me about train hopping
how was it
it's it's a it's it's a beautiful
experience man it's it's it's something
you do like uh
it's hard to explain like like
you see things you don't see like on the
road you know what i mean like you don't
go you don't you don't when you're
riding a train you're not on the road
you're on you're on a track so you're
going through places you never you know
would expect to see
on top of that it's a freight train too
so
it's it's really an interesting
experience with the wind hitting your
face and the screeching of the rails and
all that i miss it man but
it's it's a it's definitely
it has its times where it's a
a rush like an intense brush because
if it it it's such a risk if the train
doesn't kill you you know the
environment will kill you if the
environment doesn't kill you
uh the railyard police will kill you if
the rail yard police doesn't kill you
it's always something man it's a it's
definitely if you don't know what you're
doing then you could you really
you could really mess you up you know
you lose your life so
i bet you got some stories oh i do i do
man tell me what you've experienced
doing there uh
so so
train hopping uh you see things
you know like
because you're going you're going to so
many places you don't know and you're
doing so many things and like so much
can happen you know like like
i've seen i've seen things that um
uh
like
see to see somebody like like like lose
their life you know especially somebody
that you you you share share a bond with
even though you haven't known them for
too long they still make an impact on
you enough to uh you remember their face
you know
so long story short like it it's
it can be pretty brutal especially out
there because
the things that do happen
it gets real you know like it gets
really real um
so i was i was with my buddy keenan
we were with uh my brother was with us
but we we were we were writing what's
called the intermodal double stack
okay those go those go the fastest so
we're trying to get
northeast as fast as we could
um all i know is it was raining it was
raining one night i had my i had keenan
next to me and
you pair up on each carts because
there's only enough for two
and he was next to me and it was like i
want to say midnight raining pouring
rain and you always have a bottle of
whiskey on a train no matter what we
always had our bottles of whiskey
so we we were pretty uh
pretty smashed you know
long story short he uh he he stood up to
take a piss
and um
you know the rain and the metal and
he was he was
he couldn't hear me you know sit down
dude sit down he wouldn't he wouldn't
you know he wasn't processing anything
he's just drunk you know he had to do
his thing but he ended up sleeping and
he he i remember he slipped he hit his
head i tried to grab him and
i couldn't i felt my fingers i grazed
his jacket you know as he fell and he
i figured man maybe he's all right maybe
he's all right you know like he probably
just rolled out of it he's good you know
and when i when i go to see to check
you know see what happened
all i know is um
like
his his legs his legs like his lower
half was he landed on the track
his upper body was under the train you
know and then his legs
he he he got cut in half basically and
uh
like that's something that when you when
you see something like that happen it's
it's
you can't you can't really process it
you know you can't process it right then
and there he
like i i was frozen man you know i
couldn't sleep for a while either to see
to see something like that happen to my
friend you know
and uh
yeah for them to have to recover recover
him and and to tell to tell his mother
you know hey
your son died he got
into a horrible accident he got cut in
half that's just the worst thing to tell
somebody you know who has a child
it's not right man you know it's
it definitely takes its toll like i said
it takes a huge toll so
on top of that you know i've had i've
had a couple other experiences too i
mean
i want to say it was before that
happened when uh i i had ran into some
some kids they were new to the
experience too but they didn't know what
they were really doing
at the time and uh it was this couple
and um
we met in roseville i think roseville
roseville california that's a big train
train uh
town here in cali
and uh we were at the rail yard and i
was trying to teach him the ropes and
everything and uh under behind the
walmart is where the where all the
tracks are that's where everybody goes
to hop on
and uh we we stopped and talked to these
other train hopping kids
put it this way there's a lot of train
hopping gangs out there ftra isn't
around really anymore it's called
freight train riders of america but they
were pretty brutal train gang you know
so uh
but they're still train games don't get
me wrong and they're they're pretty bad
you know but we we stopped and talked to
these dirty kids long story short and uh
i don't remember exactly what we were
talking when we were trying to get
directions or something or
we're trying to ask him something and
all i know is something didn't look
right about him you know
something really didn't look right like
like i don't know if there's drugs
involved or whatever but they
i'm talking like bug-eyed looking dudes
you know like she's weird uh
everything just like happens like really
fast you know in those situations
um
one guy asked me something and i
i said no or something and he didn't
like that and
you know i i you got people in your
blind spot punching you you know i get
hit from the side you know i see guy
over here getting hit you know trying to
fight and not strong enough there's too
many you know and you end up getting
pinned down and
and uh we we they pinned us down and
they did things to her you know and made
it kind of just like
to to bring somebody uh who who they
were they were young men they were too
young and they wanted to experience
something great you know something good
and for me to
be i felt responsible for that you know
and uh
i i i want to say i ruin i ruined
two young young people's lives i just
wanted to have fun man
what happened
they uh they they
they beat the [ __ ] out of us basically
took our stuff and uh they pinned and
pinned me and oh boy down
and when basically they they were raping
her man like they raped it they raped
her
turns raping her and uh
i mean it's not really something really
easy to say you know but i'm trying to
be as blunt as i can
and uh
it's it's a very horrible experience man
that's this horrible you know even
though i didn't know them very well it
was still something nobody should ever
have to go through or see or experience
you know let alone
you know that's
that's not something that somebody
should get out of that man
you know
it's really it's really hard out there
dude especially in the train hopping
community man because uh anything could
happen at any time
you know you're when you're hopping
freight trains
and you're stopping somewhere you're
you're somewhere where uh
you're far from home man okay you're far
from home so
these other people when they see you
nobody's going to miss you you know
you're far enough to get for they could
get away you know i mean
by the time they get on the train and
leave and the cops show up whatever
whatever happens happens they're gone
they're they're they're states away you
know so
i mean anything can happen they're
fearless out there you know
it's it's a terrifying world man but but
it i want to say it's worth the uh
the experience of uh the the view the
beauty of you know the things that you
see
you know and
to the the
the destination it's not about the
destination it's about the travel you
know that's what we always say
so
[Music]
i think on top of that you just got to
be really careful
with uh
if you don't know what you're doing you
have to find somebody who knows what
they're doing who is very experienced
and um
[Music]
follow everything they say don't argue
you know
you know
don't get on the train while it's moving
this that blah blah blah and uh
you'll be fine but there's this asian
kid that for example there's an asian
kid that that was with us and he wasn't
he he wasn't listening to a damn what we
were saying man like he would tell him
uh
hey don't do that don't do that you know
he he just you said oh i know what i'm
doing i know what i'm doing
uh long story short it's always when
they're kind of got to go to the
bathroom man they [ __ ] up man but he had
to take a [ __ ] and we the train had
stopped
so uh there's this thing called slack
action when when the train stops all the
carts are catching up boom boom boom
boom boom boom so the knuckle between
the train is going like this this this
kid step between the knuckle like that
at the worst time i heard it coming and
it clamped his foot man and he was
wearing these boots and i all i remember
is i seen the toes coming out of the top
there's like a lot of nerves and and it
was it was a sight to see man like it
was everybody was frozen like we didn't
know what to do
by the time we got to the conductor to
let him know that hey this guy's stuck
you know
he had bled out so
you know so uh
yeah it's just one stupid little mistake
you know i mean and you know
you know you could [ __ ] yourself up or
kill yourself you know
basically
that's the whole rundown of it you know
how old are you now i'm 26.
at the time uh
when i started traveling i was 18 19
and i traveled for about five five years
four years
four years yeah four years
so it was like four years straight we
went to the east coast and back you know
zigzagged through the place you know it
was it was excitement and new people new
faces how would you support yourself
uh basically
we played music we had our instruments
with us you know so we we would drop a
hat down and we had like a little band
going you know we play music and we
sometimes we make like 150 bucks you
know in one run sometimes we make 60
bucks
usually it was pretty good you know it
wasn't too bad we always had our uh our
gear with us we had water food
everything packed that we needed and we
we carried a
hiking bags
so
we had everything we needed you know if
we were on the train we we were set you
know what i mean so that was the most
important part
your friends my friends
do you have friends now uh
they're all spread out you know they're
they're not it's not the same as it used
to be you know uh
i'm sure they're still out there
traveling too a few of them i know they
are
but but other than that they're they're
they're settled down some of them you
know not around anymore obviously some
of them
[Music]
might be you know strung out on the
streets somewhere you know i mean i
don't know but
right now i'm i'm kind of i'm kind of
lone wolf in it right now you know so
especially because a lot of the things
that i've seen having people with me you
know so i just don't wanna
you know the street side is a horrible
place you know i mean it can be a
horrible place man it's really hostile
out there
definitely there's things they don't
tell you there's things you don't see on
the news you know
like
it's pretty messed up
are you still in contact with your
family
my family uh yeah yeah i speak to my
family still absolutely
you know
they don't know that i'm uh out on the
streets right now but
other than that you know
they're doing good
my mom just bought her first house so
i'm pretty proud for that you know
what are you afraid of what do you worry
about now
right now i'm just
i'm just uh i'm worried about if i'm
gonna uh
if i'm ever gonna get the opportunity to
uh
get off the streets you know because uh
some people just don't make it you know
and i want to have a life
you know that's that's that's what i'm
worried about you know because it it'll
take its toll i know it will if i don't
do anything you know it'll take its toll
and
eventually it does man
i've seen it happening you know i see
i've met a few people and they're not
around anymore
so
[Music]
if you had your life to live all over
again bradley what would you have done
differently
if i had my life to live over again i
probably would have uh
[Music]
i would have finished school for sure
um i would i would probably be in
college right now or hopefully
you know um
i would do it way different you know
there's things that i seen that i wish i
could unsee
you know
that's what that's what gets me the most
man is the things that i i can't unsee
that's the worst part about it
what have you learned from your years
train hopping
being on the street
um
life like the human life man is way more
uh precious than anybody knows like
people take take it for granted you know
they laugh they laugh it's funny but
you know
it's it's real it's serious you know
what i mean like like
you could you can know this person know
you don't know if they're gonna be gone
tomorrow you don't know if you're gonna
be gone tomorrow you know like
anything happens at any given moment
don't take your life for granted
basically you know
just uh
enjoy the little things for what you
have you know it could always be better
and it could always be worse that's what
i learned
you know from experience
all right rightly thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
the best of luck from here
thank you man thanks
you